دقيقه بلشت الهزايه دوب نزلنا من البنايه
وصارت الحياطين تهدم علينا ويدوب نفذنا
بسابع والناس دروب براسها بجسمها ونزلنا
جوا على البستان تمينا من الساعه اربعه
للوجه للصبح الساعه تسعه واحنا تحت المطر
وحاليا جيني هان على المخيم
والله قضينا الليله عند جيراننا بالخيام
بالخيام وغطسنا بالوحل للركب غطسنا يعني
ذبحنا البرد انا والله طالعوني من جوه
الانقاذ
فيقتني عيلتي البنايه دعت هز شلت الويلات
راحت برا شي الحيطان كلها اتفشتني رجعتني
على
الغرفه عائلتي نزلت على الدرج هبط عليها
بيت الدرج
واولادي اثنيناتهم
نحنا باركين في البيت نايم ما حسيت مديريه
الا الارض صارت دقيت بالاولاد وصرنا نرقد
عاد الي رقدنا صارت ترج الارض في زياده
وطلعنا والله يعني لله الامر التدبير
طلعنا عراه يعني والله سترنا اي والله
بهالليل
شوي شوي